do you want to get 24 hours of battery
life with your MacBook well you can but
I am surprised by how little people know
about this now I've mentioned it a
couple times in other videos but today
I'm going to show you exactly how to set
it up and best use it how it works the
performance and the battery life that
you gain depending on which MacBook you
have now there's been many Windows
laptop companies that advertise crazy
battery life but time and time again
when we test it they fall short for
example even the new Dell XPS 13 plus
with the latest processors that cost
more than an M2 MacBook Air well that
thing died on us whereas the M2 MacBook
Air still had 40 percent battery life
remaining while having way more
performance now that was using the M2
air normally but if we are going to be
saving battery life then the battery
life can actually get up to twice as
good while still having better
performance and I'll show you that in
just a bit now three years ago I showed
you guys how to make your Intel base
MacBook run cooler and quieter and at
the same time save some battery life so
if you're running an Intel one you guys
might want to watch that video but since
then Apple released the M1 chip which
had killer performance and it had
amazing battery life it took it to the
next level but with Apple's M2 Chip a
lot of reviewers said that the battery
life actually got worse especially if
you push it because Apple ended up
boosting clock speeds running more power
and trying to maximize performance so
the chip actually looks good now that
made some people including us a bit
upset because it's almost like it's just
an overclock chip and that's why we
called it more of a stop Gap but there
was one thing that I loved about the M2
series that is the fact that the
efficiency cores got much more powerful
and with the new 14 and 16 inch MacBook
Pros instead of having only two
efficiency cores we now have four and
I'll show you guys what difference this
makes in terms of battery life now
mostly me talking about the M1 laptop so
if you have one of those make sure to
stick around but with these new M2
series if you're pushing them hard the
battery life is actually worse but for
regular mixed use they could be quite
good and with this change they're going
to get amazing so let me first show you
guys the increase of battery life with a
M2 MacBook Air you go from having around
10 hours of mixed-use battery life to
about 15 if you're going to be using
this and then if you're doing some
lighter tasks and if you're not maxing
out your brightness all the time you're
doing web browsing things like that you
can actually go up to 20 hours of
battery life now
14-inch MacBooks you're going to go from
9 hours up to 14 and with that mixed use
I'm counting like some video editing
some photo editing and tougher
productivity like that and for lighter
tasks simple stuff up to 18 hours but
the Killer is if you have a 16 inch
which has the biggest battery that you
can fit onto an airplane well that will
go from 12 hours up to 18 with mixed
productivity tasks or 24 hours for light
use and that is absolutely insane now
the way that this happens is the new low
power mode the Apple added a while ago
when they gave us this I didn't make a
big deal about it because with the M1
series it is not as good but I'll still
show you guys those numbers but with the
M2 and the new efficiency cores it is
absolutely amazing so I'm gonna start
out with the M1 Pro 16 inch laptop
giving you guys the performance
differences using this with the M1 Pro
MacBook Pro drops our single core and
multi-core performance scores but the
multi-core by very little and if we take
a look at the M2 pro version we also see
a drop but the crazy thing is even when
saving power we still get a multi-core
score of 13 000 for geekbench 5 beating
out the M1 Pro's 11 300 while getting
way better battery life now as far as
CPU power usage the M2 Pro does use more
wattage regularly and when we're using
low power mode you will see that the M2
Pro still uses a little bit more but the
kicker is with this new M2 Pro chip you
can use the low power mode and still get
better performance while using less
power with the other one now with the 14
and 16 inch MacBook Pros apple is more
targeting the amount of power that is
used for this mode to give you good
performance while saving battery life
and it works great but the really
impressive part comes in with their
lower end laptops like the MacBook Air
here when we're using low power mode you
are mostly using the efficiency cores
which is why the M2 MacBook Air gets
insane battery life compared to the
other machines because it has four of
them and they're very powerful now with
M1 MacBooks you go from about 20 watts
down to about four and a half which is
crazy that's a huge savings and battery
life but unfortunately the performance
drops so much from over 7000 to 3700
that it's not really worth using but
with the M2 Chip we also see a huge drop
in power usage but the performance drops
much less in fact the drop is about 40
percent but if we look at the average
wattage used it goes down from nine and
a half down to three and a half even
less than the M1 chip while having way
more performance almost double and
because this machine is using about a
third of the power for the CPU that's
where you can go for 10 hours of battery
life up to 20 for simple light tasks or
about 15 if you're doing things like
video editing photo editing things like
that which is crazy and that machine can
charge to 50 percent in just 30 minutes
meaning you're getting 10 hours of
battery life in just 30 minutes that is
crazy but how does it perform in low
power mode and I think you will be
surprised for blender 3D rendering the
performance dropped very little and
that's because this also affects the
graphics usage makes it way more
efficient but for video exporting it did
get quite a bit slower her but the crazy
thing is that when you compare it to the
Dell XPS with a new chip that is more
expensive the M2 air in low power mode
was still almost twice as fast while
getting about three times better Real
World battery life when you're doing
something like this now when you're
doing Simple tasks web browsing things
like that you cannot tell the difference
it is crazy and because of that I would
recommend toggling it on and off and
I'll show you how to do that easily but
first I want to show you guys the other
benefit and that is that not only do you
get killer performance this is the 14
inch right here but the fans can also
stay off while running your machine much
cooler as well so you get the full
performance of the last gen but way
better battery life cooler and quieter
which is awesome now how do you enable
this now the standard way is to go to
your your settings scroll down to
battery and then depending on your
machine it might look a little bit
different but you can click in here and
then you can select low power if you're
on battery you also have the option on
the power adapter but unless your
machine's getting hot you don't need to
do that so you just go in here and
toggle that now you can also use Siri to
do that for you if you like doing it
that way I personally do not so the best
option is to use a shortcut there's this
basic low power mode shower cut that you
can download I found it on
iphonetricks.org and that will give you
a little shortcut menu right here once
you follow instructions and you install
it and give it permission to just be
able to press it it will run and it will
enable low power mode now there's
another option called cooldown which is
very cool and you can quickly toggle it
right there in the menu you press it it
toggles on and off now this is made by
the same guy who made the Vivid app
which we showed off and that's very cool
and the best thing about this is that
they're working to give you automated
control to toggle low power mode on and
off at certain times of the day or even
depending on what app are using so
personally what I've been using is
having low power mode on almost all the
time and then if I know that I'm gonna
go do something very intensive that I
want the best performance toggle it off
render quickly and then turn it back on
the battery life has been amazing and
the system has been running very cool
with the fans shut off now once again if
you have an older Intel based machine I
would go and check out that previous
video that I recommended I'll go ahead
and Link that right over there but you
guys let me know does this change your
mind on the M2 chips and what you think
about this click that Circle above to
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
thank you